le duel aura finalement bien lieu le
binôme union de la droite composé de
Michel logier et Laurence Trochu arrivve
en tête au premier tour avec 40,65 % des
voix les socialistes François de Lig et
Sandrine grandambe obtiennent 35,93 %
des suffrages le Front national lui
obtient 14,30 % et le binôme divivers
gauche 9,13 % des voix un résultat qui
satisfait le maire de Montini Michel
logier ce résultat vous l'attendiez ce
résultat je l'attendais je espérer et
pour moi c'est une belle belle réussite
après une bonne campagne donc ça veut
dire que les habitants de Montini sont
fidèles à leur mère et souhaitent qu'il
les accompagneent encore plus loin et
les habitants de guilloncour aussi
souhaitent que je les représente au sein
de l'assemblée départementale du côté
des socialistes on préfère saluer la
mobilisation des électeurs et se
projeter directement vers le 2e tour de
scrutin moi je je suis satisfait de ce
premier tour je suis satisfait parce
qu'on voit que
les habitants de Montini et de
guillancour ont compris qu'il fallait se
mobiliser alors évidemment on
souhaiterait tous qu'il ait plus de
participation je pense que pour le
deuxème tour il va falloir à un moment
donné avoir une mobilisation
supplémentaire c'est certain mais qu'on
peut très bien contrairement à ce qui
éta annoncé encore une fois faire la
différence 894 voix seulement séparent
les deux binômes présents au second tour
cela devrait donc se jouer avec le
report de voie en ce qui n concerne les
consignes de vote ont toujours été clair
là-dessus on ne se désiste absolument
pas en faveur d'un autre parti pour les
consignes de vote on va pas décider ça
nous tout seul donc on va se réunir avec
les sympathisants avec les militants et
demain on pourra prendre une décision la
décision du binom Front de Gauche Europe
Écologie Les Verts devrait être connu
mardi